c'est non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais qu'elle roulait
les balades au caire
ça
[Musique]
drucker pas là
c'est pas moi qui l'aï il est resté
bloqué sur la tour eiffel depuis la
semaine dernière alors le coup de pouce
et que je sais fichtre chez moi qui
arrive ça c'est celle à qui arrive après
que son nouveau look avec son nouveau
look
je prends bonjour je suis emmerdé parce
que normalement c'est l'émission de
drucker et puis les points là bas on
alors moi j'ai ses fils alors je dis que
j'ai dit c'est là qu'arrive je suis
passé confiture au courant parce qu on
se gèle tout à l'heure bon après y'a
fugain [ __ ] je ne supporte pas ce truc
[Musique]
thierry o
les nanas sont bienvenues mais qui est
vraiment à michel salut on sait bien que
ça va qu'à moitié parce que c'est
normalement c'est drucker qui devait
présenter le truc qui les voilà donc les
hommes est toutefois ben oui alors oui
mais vous pouvez rentrer m qu'est-ce
qu'il ya encore derrière
patricia kaas chantera bien le bleu elle
chantera très bien le boulot ça me suis
content de l'avoir patricia je suis très
important ou plus soit là parce que
personne chante le blues que toi alors
voilà je t'explique normalement c'est
drucker qui est là mais il a fait une
émission samedi sur le tour eiffel il
restait bloquée du tc spirou qui réalise
les complètement et donc moi je ne sais
pas ce que le mieux que tu vas y que tu
as à faire c'est de rentrer 1
et drucker non et ça c'est quoi derrière
ça c'est giraudeau s'est levé tout le
monde c'est le mec a plus qu'a refusé le
rôle de 3e
[Musique]
c'est lié les peines à celje
madame scellier quelle joie de voir
bonjour bonjour monsieur bernard tu vas
bien je suis très content de te voir
mais je suis embêté parce que drucker
est pas là non c'est moi qui fais les
citoyens non mais il était il va venir
tu veux non mais moi je suis à niamey tu
rentres tu rentres quand même devant il
ya des boissons il ya tous oui tu
rentres tu rentres un tankiste ya
derrière les murailles hell d'ac muriel
dax une aristocrate belle ce que ça veut
pas dire que l'iphone os et c'est
pourquoi une chambre du côlon que de ça
ce sont des trucs pas très intéressant
mais bonjour muriel tabac muriel bas de
pas bavard après y'a gainsbourg qui
devrait arriver dans quel état
c'est lui le pauvre homme [ __ ] ce
sujet ni qui ressemble à une poubelle et
il est content
et maintenant qui c'est celui-là moi je
pourrai manger
moi ça me fait chier tu vois tes pas mon
boulot moi j'étais là pour faire un truc
ouais bah voilà le professeur léon
schwartzenberg de cancérologues des six
chaînes avant qu'israël marceau selon me
marc sont bons et que ça alors là
carrément un autocar au relais
ohlala là je sais pas qui c'est c'est un
autobus d'émigrer
il faut il faut dans ce genre d'émission
il faut une certaine proportion devenu
de d'émigrer sinon
[Musique]
mory kante canettes il ya des
l'alsacien québécois c'est pareil tout
ça c'est des belles salut bonjour il
sonné bonjour j'aime beaucoup les gens
de couleur
bonjour vous avez changé quelque chose
on va je suis michèle longueur moyenne à
quoi y'en as francophone pour yann à
michel drucker
ça lui allait aller nancy ont serré la
main tu comprends si je me sers la
paluche à tout le monde les -20 passé
voilà et moi qu'est ce que je fais la
mémoire pierre
oui je suis là je suis arrivé bt ou
betty le je vais saluer le public et je
te retrouve tout à l'heure ah mais non
merci pas ce mois-là à verser elle avait
de quoi de neuf c'est non non
[Musique]